yeah i don't know you were yelling
unreasonable yeah i don't scream at you
okay time for the latest installment of
change my mind where we rationalize our
positions on controversial topics click
the description to see previous
installments now this week
we decided to take on the current media
narrative in that president trump is a
racist
you know what i don't buy it how about
you is donald trump a racist
responsible for a rise in white
supremacy comment below
unfortunately before we could even begin
the conversation at our table
some folks were cocked and ready i would
love for you to sit down you know what
he said right
yeah what did he say are you talking
about he said that we need to close our
borders to illegal immigrants
go home right he was telling remember
that the chant at his rally
what was the chant he led at israel go
ahead you tell me
i have no idea yeah go back home go back
to the country you came from
how is that racist it's racist because
you need to understand they are already
home
would you like me to explain to you no
if you can't if you can't honestly you
know what the chance is
you know exactly what that chance is you
don't you don't you just said you don't
yeah you just said you have no idea what
the chan is no i do uh it's basically
you just said he said go back
home go back home i was something like
that okay had
nothing to do with people being
minorities i'll recognize the actual
quote
but it's just exactly normal you'll
the gop you know they they talk to
mueller
as if he's a child there is no precedent
for this
when uh when a president is completely
corrupt
completely owned by a hostile foreign uh
putin
there's no precedent for that it's an
unwritten
rule in america that you defend your
country that's what mueller did
there was no exoneration will i be able
to speak
am i allowed to speak you said i i
tapped your life no no apparently not no
apparently you're not allowed to speak
me is that okay uh no that's not okay so
it's not okay for me to speak
to my face and pretend you know if you
pretend to not remember what that chant
is
tell me what the exact words are the
audience seems to want to remember what
the exact chances are
tell me what the exact chants are go
back home
go back home go back home back home
lock her up as evidence okay he's going
to be compromised by
putin we've gone from he wants to become
the united states of putin
this isn't really what we do with change
my mind anyone's welcome to sit down
my mind and have a civil discussion this
guy is just crazy
as if they squat and dump come on we're
not going to have this conversation if
you know what you're talking about
any time back to the country you came
from white people anyone think
president donald trump is a racist we
hear all day today we've been hearing
that regarding uh
the shooting that occurred in el paso
yep you know if you if you benefit from
the kkk
you are a racist you are a racist what
if you condemn the kkk
he never has he never will our nation
must condemn
racism bigotry and white
supremacy when you open your heart to
patriotism
there is no room for prejudice
racism is evil including the kkk
neo-nazis white supremacists and
other hate groups that are repugnant to
everything
we hold dear as americans sure he did
not out loud
how many contacts do you have to see
before you realize donald trump is a
putin production
how about facts trump islam supporter
many times to come up and say one's
how many people here support donald
trump to a degree
okay now by same show of hands how many
people here think putin is a
[Music]
there you go so maybe we can sit down
common ground doesn't really say
anything man
well sure you just said every trump
supporter not at all everyone here trump
supporters
not fans of putin and you trump
supporters cannot be trusted
they're lying all of them are lying i
would love to sit down with you if you
would like to talk
i doubt it i really would yeah there's
nothing to talk about
at this point there's nothing to talk
about okay i listen
anyone who agrees disagrees is welcome
to sit down and have a conversation
hopefully you can make a better
case of the gentleman over there um i
don't think donald's conquering your
country
donald trump is not a racist donald
trump is a race changed my mind
present some factual information if you
support donald trump
you are absolutely a racist so all of
you here are racist i just want to make
sure including you
miss brown lady yeah you're a white
you're a white supremacist if i ever saw
one slavery there were people
yeah let's just sit down we don't have
to disagree i'm just because you seem
pretty passionate in your responses here
now he just said and i was trying to
reiterate to make sure that i understood
him correctly
but i think you all heard him say that
if you support donald trump you are a
racist
so you heard that and you said that you
do support donald trump
one degree or another during the times
of slavery why and what do you make of
what does that mean
[Music]
she didn't live at welfare she always
worked for her my father
took two jobs right so then we had open
borders we had people coming in here
living off child benefits my parents
worked for those beneficials
and you know you have people in from all
cultures out there and they don't
assimilate
you've had problems so when you hear
president donald trump say
we need to secure our borders we need to
make sure that the illegal immigrants
you don't hear that as a brownfields
annoying you hear that as
illegal immigrants uncharacteristically
i mean that sounds entirely reasonable
and people out there that's right i'm
from europe we had terrorist attacks
like being called a liar stop supporting
water after france that was more about
the parish after manchester so a
terrorist can get away without
popularity start digging under the
obstruction of china
my parents are america lovers so my
parents came here when i was little well
we would love to have you if you can
come out here what do you do i'm a
teacher so i work i work in the left
wing
yeah you work in a very left wing and we
had a meeting a couple weeks ago and one
of my colleagues didn't agree with me
about trump they had a little bit of a
fight
when the cause gave me hillary clinton
for president mock to tease me oh really
but i as immigrant my my parents are
immigrants i was born in the netherlands
but i support strong but if you don't
have strong borders you don't have a
country
right europeans they are too comfortable
if the world were to
you know they are too comfortable they
don't protect the borders they think
everybody
who doesn't believe herself to support
the kkk as far as i understand so
uh we just want to make sure we clarify
that i didn't want people to see you and
be like does she support the kkk you
know
they could do that you know you don't
know what's on under those robes so
i understand that now well thank you
very much for saying i appreciate it i'm
sorry that you couldn't be more
productive we have to move locations
so anyone who just wants to yell and
accuse people of being a racist
stay here anyone who wants to sit down
and have a disagreement of opinions
we're gonna go over here and everyone is
[Music]
welcome
and i don't know if you guys see this
and this is something that we deal with
a lot
and i want you all to be aware of it
when you watch the media there's a big
difference between arguing facts and by
the way
there can be facts that present both
sides of the argument i understand that
sometimes you'll show up and someone
will present a really compelling
argument from the left
that being said there's a big difference
between arguing facts or even presenting
your opinion
and immediately attributing a motive to
your opposition
right that's what happens when you say
your opposition you've all been accused
of being racist
you've all been accused of uh being
putin supporters you've all been accused
of
supporting the kkk that shuts down the
discussion before it begins
and that's something that we try not to
do so i appreciate that everyone is here
everyone's been civil
we haven't had anyone who disagrees
willing to sit down yet but
you know listen i want to do it in good
things
luckily after we moved our table and had
some distance between us and bruce
people who disagreed were willing to sit
down
and we had some pretty productive
conversations i think he tried to take
the uh
the free phone away yeah that doesn't
mean he's a racist that is racist people
are arrested in germany
jailed for speech no no they're arrested
they're arrested if they use hateful
speech
because of course they are okay
off so you want nazis you guys started
it
more of those conversations next tuesday
don't forget to support us by joining up
at mug club for 99 dollars annually 69
for students veterans active military
louder with crowder.com it's the only
way to keep these videos going
as well as access the full daily show
and entire blaze catalog
now finally realizing he was no longer
the center of attention this crazy
leftist decided that he wanted to sit
down
you want to sit down and talk sure what
do you what do you think
i don't know i don't know if he's
reasonable oh are you kidding me yeah i
don't know you were yelling unreasonable
yeah i don't scream at you i obliged
with some very clear conditions all
right the only thing is you have to
promise that
when we're done we're done when you
leave you can't just sit here and not
let anyone else sit down oh no
no i get up no matter what yeah and
you're not gonna throw me up i'll get up
one
time they can't just sit here and not
let anyone else sit down oh no
no i get up no matter what yeah you're
not going to throw me up i'll get up
when it's time
whatever it takes that's true yeah
really seriously i don't think so
have fun with it fun fun crowd
it's a fun crowd it's been a great crowd
good supporters what's your name
bruce or jesus christ depending on on
your uh ability to recognize yourself in
the mirror
okay i'll go with bruce so bruce it's
actually jesus christ you'll go with
jesus christ
i'll go with bruce okay so bruce i don't
believe that president donald trump
is not a racist the reason the reason
you should go with god
is because i'm right here in front of
you and like you can actually learn
something from
helping to save our country and saving
the world okay we have to get all minds
on uh you know all hands on deck all
minds on point
protect the truth jesus christ exactly
that's that's how that's the correct way
to pronounce my name jesus christ is the
correct way to pronounce my name
you stumbled upon it there you go i'm
i'm serious about your past okay i don't
believe that uh
i'm you you're me there's only one me in
all reality yeah it's
okay we'll go seriously there is we'll
go back to the jesus christ thing
uh but uh this is the reason we're here
we have the sign i don't you know listen
i don't buy it that donald trump's a
racist so you were yelling earlier
pretty upset why because he he might not
get he might not get elected
if people believe he's a racist that's
why you don't like it's not what i don't
believe that he's a racist so again it
feels uncomfortable
you know to feel like you're a racist
because you support donald trump if you
if you sit down
is that why if you sit down the onus is
on you
to change my mind that's whole idea part
of it part of
changing your mind is is is revealing
your motives
why you don't want to see trump as a
racist you have motives
and yeah you do you definitely have
motives you want to get trump elected
right
you're a trump supporter you want to see
him get elected you don't want people to
think he's a racist
and because if they think trump's a
racist and you're you're a trump
supporter they're going to
see you as a racist and you don't like
how that feels so you're motivated
to convince people trump's not a racist
whether he's a racist or not you
couldn't give a crap
but you want to convince everyone he's
not a racist yeah
so he gets elected so everything you've
just said is incorrect
uh no it's exactly correct exactly
accurate everything you've just said is
incorrect no
it's exactly correct it's exactly
accurate and it's in the realm of
something that couldn't let's assume you
were
saying is it you said you were going to
sit down
and finish speaking i bet you can't call
something i say incorrect when it's
actually correct sure i can call it
incorrect
and i can say your your statement of
saying it was incorrect was incorrect
okay but anyway go ahead you're a racist
you're a racist you're a tried and true
racist how am i a racist
i think you're a racist okay the fact
that you've made this your his own day
i think you're racist i think you're
anti-jewish by insulting uh uh people of
the jewish ethnicity claiming that you
are jesus christ
no i think you're racist prove to me
you're not a racist
okay you're not a racist
there is no proof you you can't prove
you're not a racist
you can prove yourself a racist though
oh okay you can't
but i'm saying your motive is that
you're a racist if
brown people in cages have you ever seen
by pedophiles uh you're a racist
if if you if you stand up and say i'm
jesus christ i am you you are me there's
only one me in all reality
uh let's have the back of life itself
and not go extinct
that doesn't make you a racist no it
doesn't make you a hater of jews
it makes you a person saying hey i am
you you are me
there's only one me and all of reality
you're racist let's have the back of
life itself let's save life from going
extinct
honesty and truthful for the lies of
pride yeah that matters you should be
more honest about your races i am honest
about
who i am i understand the racists that
you are
i understand the racist that you i think
you're a racist you are a complete
racist
you're right inside your head you're a
racist you are a racist i am robber you
are racist
because you're the only one insulting
anyone of color here are a nice brand
new netherlands
oh really thank you racist you're good
you're absolutely out of your mind you
didn't prove to us that you're not a
racist
but hopefully you're remembering listen
dummy it's a thought exercise i'm here
to protect our country
it's a thought exercise if you attribute
motivation productive consciousness
the me within assault listen okay
all right that's enough oh power all
right get up get up and leave
there's no power above you you're below
you okay and your responsibility to save
life from extinction
yeah i'm gonna stand right here
hey boy i'm going after my stuff here
too i didn't take his stuff i even
raised my hand to you once
once this crap
jesus christ ladies and gentlemen yeah
that's straight from me jesus christ in
my butt
this of course comes from the proverbs
and jesus christ in his anguish cried
out
and his detractors should lick his
[Music]
i don't think jesus is gonna like the
way this one ends up
for your viewing pleasure here are the
police officers upon reviewing the
footage notifying bruce christ that
should he press charges he would find
himself immediately in jail as well let
him go
let him go it's telling me more about
you guys than anything else
you're destroying credibility of the
most important law enforcement
officers we've got but let him go let
him go
he politely declined it's my word
against i get arrested if he gets
arrested
that would be easy to just say that
bruce christ is a crazy person
and he is but where oh where have i
heard these exact same
arguments before well jesus christ of
course he's racist
basically threatening us with going full
racist
suggesting that the entire trump vote
was racist
and by racists i i i think
i think yes do you believe president
trump is
a racist yeah yeah no question look at
what he's done
it's racist that statement of trump's is
old-school
racism that doesn't make you not racist
it actually makes you racist if you
support somebody who does racist things
that makes you racist present some
factual information if you support
donald trump
you are absolutely a racist this
president
is encouraging greater racism they are
softening the ground
for straight up racism out of the
president's twitter account
he's launching a blatantly racist attack
on four duly elected members of the
united states of house of
representatives
his own words and actions are racist too
there's never been a president
in american history who's been as so
openly racist and divisive he's racist
and no black people can't be racist
this is not the first nor will it be the
last time we hear disgusting bigoted
language from the president
you are great brown people in cages to
be overseen by pedophiles uh you're
racist